foreign
[Music]
Texas bar there's a 38 year old man
that's in there trying to convince his
father-in-law to sign the divorce papers
on behalf of his daughter so it's like
you know like you're trying to divorce
your wife she won't sign it so you go to
her dad okay and you're like hey sign
this [ __ ] why would he sign it because
that's property do you need the father
of the spouse or something I think
that's how that works unless she has
like what's he trying to convince his
father to convince his daughter he might
have been yeah it might have been that
or was it like you walked her down the
aisle and gave it to me I want it back
this is the receipt take it back it
might have been that it says he was
trying to get him to sign something so I
don't know so he's in there trying to
argue with this guy the um that
father-in-law is refusing to do it so
the guy headbutts him to death oh my God
head butt his father-in-law two dead in
the bar oh my God I think a total of
three headbutts whoa that's a lot of
three took three how old was the
father-in-law again oh that'll do it
what if he was just like he heard his
favorite song and he was just head
banging and he was doing one of these
you know
and then it was like oh
it's probably
coming
damn pretty rough Jesus in two pieces
that's really [ __ ] up you guys ever
been head-butted no I have I heard it's
really bad really I have how did the
[ __ ] did that happen who had butted you
in the middle of choreography no this is
such a i i there's there's no moral to
this there's no random it's there's no
moral to this I was um
I had a room in it in college uh my
freshman year we were in the dormitories
right and then we're friends and then
one thing leads to another and then
we're like kind of wrestling in the
dorms you know what I mean just play
wrestling yeah and then one thing leaves
another again and like it's like the
vibe changed you know 10 powered Rangers
turned into real fights because you were
you were beating him up and he got mad
bro maybe and then like when like the
vibe and and I think my cousin was there
to win the city or something like that
um Vibe changes I think it's done
and there's this Awkward Moment of pause
where nothing happens and then he fully
head butts me in like the chest chest no
no it's a weird place to have did like a
ram move yeah he just ran minty like
zidane the [ __ ] out of me you know what
I mean um but it's like a head is a very
that's hard bro yeah and maybe and maybe
also like it was like a shocking
experience because like when you you
know you don't really see that part of
the body coming at you when you're like
play wrestling and stuff like that and
just [ __ ] hit me in Hell or hurt too
did you knock the wind out of you what
was that didn't knock the wind out of
you I think I was more just shocked as
[ __ ] you know what I mean because the
energy also just changed it wasn't like
play wrestling anymore it was like dude
what the [ __ ] is wrong yeah you know
what I mean but I just remember thinking
to myself oh yeah weird yeah and the
thing is I was looking up articles uh
and I saw this article too right and
then for some reason when I read that
article uh title and stuff and I looked
into it that was the first thing that
came to my mind as well my roommate
head-butting me you've probably never
even think of that yeah I never would
have thought about it how'd you guys
talk it out after or yeah no it got
really weird and then you like left the
room
and it was a [ __ ] wild and awkward
and then for me I was just kind of like
uh I think that was just weird I'm just
not even gonna worry about it because
you know if you worry about something
that's like you guys didn't talk about
it ever nice not really and then he came
back later he's like I'm gonna go get uh
I'm gonna go to McDonald's you want to
come with you know when something's so
out of whack that like the easiest way
to like you know what I mean if you die
don't acknowledge yeah it just like
makes it more wax I gotta live with this
guy I mean I guess that is that doesn't
mean it was just so random guys could do
that [ __ ] though that's what I'm saying
I have an unspoken agreement that that
was weird let's it's too awkward to talk
about it let's just be we're both
embarrassed by it exactly which is why
I'm like I'm like uh not at all [ __ ]
relating to a guy who's gonna head but
his [ __ ] father-in-law to death but
just genuinely I'm like oh human beings
do that from time to time but three
times they like there's something clicks
the vibe changes and they [ __ ] get
aggressive dude headphones are real you
can even shock the dude it was a
surprise attack is it that's what bass
rutton said people don't expect they
expect the hands yeah that's right
that's right and said to come with
someone like this and then you can head
butt out of nothing he's he's cool yeah
you're right here you could really
damage somebody is that an illegal move
so in and like MMA fights there are
situations where like people's heads ah
that hurts though or people without his
boat people's heads Collide like when
they're both trying to throw and they
hit each other and double cares like
there's some serious damage that is done
like guys get cut oh cause it's just
bones you can't intentionally head butt
someone I don't know it's it's not legal
at all but it does do a lot of dance
from both sides to see what happens
yeah he has a head like a Muay Thai
Fighter you know what's funny is I do I
have something weird in the back of my
skull that um because back when I would
hit my head all the time my dad would
always bug me to go get a CAT scan and
I'm like all right fine let's see if
there's any hemorrhaging doubt it so I
went in there I know it just caught the
cockiest guy in the machine so I get it
scanned and then the doctor's like huh
that's weird your head's shaped like so
it's like a circle but right in the back
I have an extra lump like this oh [ __ ]
he's like normally when you when people
have that you know like the line into
the where their brain is it'll it'll go
like that like
that's the whole like shape of the skull
but he said yours goes like this whoa so
he said that I just have an extra bone
layer like bone yeah like a little bone
knee pad at the back of my head because
I I've hit it so many times on accident
holy [ __ ] like whiplashing onto the
ground and [ __ ] yeah yeah he's like
you're lucky you didn't get uh internal
bleeding but you did develop just more
bone bonuses like your elbow so it's
your super exactly like my elbow yeah
same [ __ ] damn you got an extra bone we
also got extra bone huh I have calcium
deposits they're like turtle shells
isn't that a good thing if it's just
enough to protect you more because your
body's like this guy gets a lot of
damage yeah but it's it's kind of
adaptation it's it's that you got to hit
that sweet spot you're a [ __ ] mutant
dog Ryan is wild
but yeah that's why if you look back
like that's kind of why I like grow my
hair out back here because if I had a
bald head it would just look like I
absorbed my twin in the womb
they look kind of weird yeah I never
broken a bone like a hardcore break
where I needed a cast but I realized I I
think I broke a lot of things like
fractured a lot of things like hairline
fractures or like yeah because like um
my my my toes I couldn't close it for
like six months and it was like sharp
pain and I'm like what the [ __ ] and then
I read up and it was like oh yeah that's
kind of like a broken toe and I'm like I
didn't even know when I did that well
like when I got kicked in the rib
um I read it as like oh my spleen got uh
sprained I got kicked into spleen I got
sprained is that a thing but then the
spleen got spring bro cake
that's close it was good there's another
word for like a bruise like a rupture or
something that sounds like something
Mike Tyson would say
if spleen got ruptured it went from like
casually like
I had a broken rib for because they said
that after two months if it doesn't heal
whatever the connections tour or
whatever and then I'm like all of it is
though at the end of the day it says how
they're gonna what they're gonna do is
give you painkillers and uh and that's
it well broken rib you can't do a whole
I can't cast this stuff you can't so I
was just like what's the [ __ ] point
so then the point of these yeah I I
throughout life I had a lot of uh
injuries that I just thought were
bruised or like just something [ __ ] up
and I was like oh maybe it'll go away
but then now I'm like oh [ __ ] they were
actually broken bones but I didn't know
the difference between
fracture Splinter whatever all that yeah
strain spring I just never snapped it
because it wasn't like a traditional
break and that never snap in like a
skater break yeah
interesting yeah well ribs are the you
can go a long time without realizing you
have a broken rib
you like really my dad fell off a ladder
one time and he didn't realize it
forever this fool does x-ray for a
living oh what he didn't even go he's
not in the X-ray he does x-rays for a
living but he was on a ladder I'm
confused
there's a really big x-ray okay
a dad who yeah but he just was like oh
funny and then he just checked it out
himself and I was like well there's a
line right through the old you know
so you can go a long time because even
healing it you just like there's no it's
just time yeah so you just like don't
watch comedies for a while so if this
guy killed the father-in-law I bet you
him and the chick are going to divorce
now
what he wanted it's crazy that she
wanted to stay with him a [ __ ] Maniac
like this she's like I'm not signing it
well maybe not until like her demands
were met or whatever yeah that's
probably what it was it's really like
down to alimony agreements and [ __ ]
right have you guys been through a
divorce before no
okay just checking
would you like to share something with
the class well it just reminded me
because like um my friend she's been
divorced totally [ __ ] forget because
like you know when they're with a new
person like oh yeah you forget their
past life especially if you didn't know
them in their previous marriage right so
I was just talking I'm like man like I
made a joke about divorce and stuff she
goes oh yeah like me and I'm like oh
yeah that's right huh
so I'm like how many more divorced
people do I know dude I totally forgot
because that part caught me off guard
divorce is for horror
[Music]
could you imagine was it like what Steve
thinks an Anthony joke is where he's
like people get divorced sure got smelly
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
Paul got divorced because he's a dancer
[Music]
foreign
[Music]